bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat un an après à
l'assemblée nationale le sénat sans par
cet après-midi de l'examen d'une
proposition de loi socialiste qui vise à
interdire le bisphénol a dans les
contenants alimentaires alors le
bisphénol a est une substance chimique
très répandu
on la trouve par exemple à l'intérieur
des cannettes ou encore des boîtes de
conserve pourtant cette substance
chimique a été classés toxiques pour la
reproduction par l' agence de sécurité
sanitaire de l'alimentation
en commission les sénateurs ont
néanmoins choisi de reporter de 2014 à
2015 la mise en oeuvre de ce principe de
précaution estimant que cela pouvait
être difficile pour les industriels
d'appliquer le principe de précaution
aussi rapidement ce qui a suscité à
l'abstention des sénateurs communistes
sur ce texte en commission ils auraient
souhaité quant à une application
beaucoup plus rapide alors tout de suite
direction l'hémicycle pour débattre de
ce texte bonne après midi à tous
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion de
la proposition de loi adoptée par
l'assemblée nationale visant à la
suspension de la fabrication de
l'importation de l'exportation et de la
mise sur le marché de tout
conditionnement à vocation alimentaire
contenant du bisphénol a dans la
discussion générale la parole est à
madame marisol touraine ministre des
affaires sociales et de la santé
vous avez la parole madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
rapporteure mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
je suis heureuse de pouvoir intervenir
devant vous pour dans le cadre de
l'examen de cette proposition de loi qui
est déjà ancienne puisque elle vient de
l'assemblée nationale et c'est vrai que
l'examen de ce texte intervient dans un
contexte particulier sur lequel je
souhaite attirer votre attention
il correspond en effet à une prise de
conscience dont je crois nous devons
collectivement n'aurait joué en matière
de santé publique la protection de nos
concitoyens doit seul guider notre
action nous devons être intransigeant le
principe de précaution n'est pas une
sanction
il est trop souvent présenté comme tel
mais pour le gouvernement les choses
sont claires dès lors que la santé de
nos concitoyens est en jeu la question
des intérêts des industriels doit être
examinée de façon relative cette règle
est intangible
nous savons désormais que la qualité de
l'environnement est un déterminant
fondamental de notre état de santé
l'impact sanitaire de certains produits
fabriqués devenue une préoccupation
nationale et communautaire majeur nous
ignorons la composition de nombreux
objets qui nous entourent
il est donc parfaitement légitime de
nous interroger sur leurs effets pour
notre santé dans certains cas leur
caractère nocif est avéré c'est pourquoi
l'initiative reach doit être soutenu et
amplifier elle permet de développer une
base étendue de connaissances sur les
produits utilisés dans les pays de
l'union européenne
je veux profiter de cette intervention
devant vous pour rendre hommage à
l'engagement précurseur d'un
parlementaire députés et non
sénateur gérard bat sa croisade contre
le bisphénol a a débuté en 2009
à cette date il a inscrit inscrits dans
sa commune de saint jean en haute
garonne
l'interdiction d'utiliser des biberons
au bisphénol
en 2010 la mobilisation de l'opposition
d'alors nous a permis à l'assemblée
nationale de franchir une première étape
décisive
l'interdiction de l'utilisation des
biberons contenant du bisphénol a qui
fut votée à l'unanimité par les deux
assemblées
aujourd'hui il ne s'agit de franchir une
étape supplémentaire et d'aller plus
loin
le bisphénol a fait l'objet d'une
vigilance particulière aux niveaux
international et national de nombreuses
études relatifs à ces effets noté nocifs
sur la santé sont venus en effet alerté
les pouvoirs publics du fait de la
ressemblance de sa molécule avec celles
des autres aux des oestrogènes
on sait maintenant depuis longtemps que
le bisphénol a est un perturbateur
endocrinien
les premières interrogations sur ses
effets date des années 30
et pourtant il a fallu attendre 2010
pour que l'ex agence française de
sécurité sanitaire des aliments l'absa
reconnaissent la présence de signaux
d'alert dans les études scientifiques en
l' agence nationale de sécurité de
l'alimentation du travail et de
l'environnement lance s accable un peu
plus le bisphénol a
les risques encourus par l'homme serait
accru durant certaines périodes de la
vie
il concernerait plus particulièrement
des populations dites fragiles tels que
les nourrissons les femmes enceintes ou
les femmes allaitantes
face à de telles incertitudes qui ne
concerne donc plus uniquement les
nouveaux nés il serait irresponsable de
ne pas appliquer strictement le principe
de précaution les données dont nous
disposons nous permettent d'établir
deux conclusions tout d'abord il a été
démontré que le bisphénol a est toxique
pour l'animal ensuite nous savons que
cette molécule est directement associés
à certaines pathologies humaines
je pense en particulier aux maladies
métaboliques ou cardiovasculaires j'ai
aussi à l'esprit le développement des
cas d'obésité dont les enfants et les
adolescents sont les premières victimes
puisqu'il s'agit de santé publique nous
devons le dire clairement nous ne
pouvons pas laisser faire nous ne
pouvons pas simplement laisser le cours
des choses aller parce que le risque ne
peut pas être supporté par le
consommateur
le rôle des pouvoirs publics est
d'encadrer de réglementer de contrôler
et le cas échéant de sanctionner la
responsabilité du décideur public est
d'autant plus déterminante que le
bisphénol a entre dans la composition de
nombreux objets dont nos concitoyens
dont nous mêmes d'ailleurs faisons un
usage quotidien
cette substance est notamment utilisé
vous le savez bien pour la fabrication
d'un grand nombre de contenants
alimentaires les dents je les dangers
qui sont liées sont importants car le
bisphénol a peut spontanément migrer
vers les aliments
c'est pourquoi il y as exactement un an
des députés ont cosigné une proposition
de loi qu'elle j'avais d'ailleurs à
poser mon nom qui a été portée donc par
gérard bapt à l'assemblée nationale
cette loi vise je veux si tu suspendre
la fabrication l'importation
l'exportation et la mise sur le marché
de tout conditionnement à vocation
alimentaire contenant du bisphénol a
cette démarche s'inscrivait dans la
continuité de la loi interdisant
l'utilisation de cette molécule dans les
biberons
il s'agit bien de compléter les
dispositifs de protection des
consommateurs
le législateur doit prendre toutes ses
responsabilités en matière de santé
environnement l'attentisme ne peut pas
être envisager ou accepter et notre
devoir est de protéger au plus
les populations les plus vulnérables des
effets néfastes du bisphénol les
avancées qui ont été réalisées sont le
fruit d'un travail commun conduit par
les deux assemblées visant à protéger
les consommateurs
le 12 octobre 2011 la proposition de loi
a été adopté en première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale par un vote
unanime des députés
la détermination de votre rapporteur
patricia china geo temps que son
efficacité et sa célérité nous
permettent aujourd'hui d'examiner ce
texte et de le réactualiser la
conférence environnementale a permis de
rappeler l'engagement du gouvernement
sur les questions de santé environnement
le premier ministre a annoncé lors de
son discours de clôture qu'il soutenait
l'interdiction du bisphénol a dans
l'ensemble des contenants alimentaires
c'est donc dans cette démarche que je
m'inscris devant vous aujourd'hui au nom
du gouvernement pour soutenir la
proposition de loi qui est examinée est
engagée nous engager dans la voie de
l'interdiction de se baigner a dès le
1er janvier 2013 tous les contenants
alimentaires produits avec du bisphénol
a à destination des enfants de moins de
3 ans seront interdits et si l'on suit
le texte de votre proposition de loi au
1er janvier 2015
plus aucun contenants alimentaires
fabriqués avec du bisphénol a ne sera
autorisé je sais que il y à des débats
et nous les aurons dans un instant il y
à des débats sur la date d'entrée en
vigueur de ce texte mais je voudrais
attirer votre attention sur le fait que
en s'engageant dans la direction
proposait par cette proposition de loi
la france serait pionnière en la matière
au niveau européen et je crois que dès
lors qu'il n'ya plus de doute sur la
nocivité
ce bisphénol a dès lors qu'une première
étape a été franchie avec l'interdiction
des biberons que les industriels ont été
informés de la perspective d'une
interdiction plus générale nous devons
avancer tout en donnant évidemment le
temps aux industriels de s'adapter dans
la mesure où du temps a été passé entre
l'adoption de la proposition de loi à
l'assemblée et l'examen d'aujourd'hui il
paraît normal que la date puisse être
fixé au 1er d'entrée en vigueur du texte
puisse être fixé au 1er janvier 2015
cette proposition de loi donc si elle
est adaptée adopté ce que je souhaite et
je souhaite qu'elle le soit vous verrez
à l'unanimité fait partie d'un processus
plus large qu'il nous faut poursuivre la
conférence des 14 et 15 septembre a
traduit notre volonté de faire vivre la
démocratie environnementale
elle nous a notamment permis de fixer
des objectifs et d'établir une méthode
pour faire face aux risques sanitaires
environnementaux au cours de la table
ronde sur la santé environnement j'ai eu
l'occasion d'évoquer les enjeux liés à
l'apparition de nouveaux risques dits
émergents source d'incertitude voire de
controverses leurs conséquences sur la
santé peuvent être difficiles à
appréhender et à caractériser
il soulève donc des inquiétudes
légitimes il nous faut promouvoir les
recherches sur ces produits
en adaptant les méthodologies disponible
parce que ces études doivent être menées
à grande échelle
j'attends beaucoup d'une mobilisation
communautaire et international à
plusieurs reprises j'ai rappelé ma
volonté de faire de la prévention des
risques sanitaires environnementaux un
axe majeur de la politique de santé dans
notre pays dans le domaine des
perturbateurs endocriniens l'action du
gouvernement reposera sur trois piliers
le premier
c'est la coordination des actions de
recherche d' expertise d'information du
public et de réflexion sur l'encadrement
réglementaire pour cela un groupe de
travail associant l'ensemble des parties
prenantes sera mise en place très
rapidement
sa mission sera de me présenter d'ici
juin 2013
les grands axes d'une stratégie
nationale le deuxième pilier
c'est la priorisation de nos actions
elle reposera sur les résultats des
expertises dont nous disposons
aujourd'hui nous traitons de la question
du bisphénol a
néanmoins d'autres perturbateurs
endocriniens comme les phtalates par
exemple doivent se doivent faire l'objet
d'une attention particulière
le crédit d'une étude se mesure à l'aune
de son indépendance
pour chaque sujet il faudra donc aborder
le problème en nous fondant sur une
expertise plurielle et contradictoire
des tâches et des intérêts privés
enfin le troisième pilier de ma
politique concerne les produits qui
pourraient se substituer à ces
substances nocives
il est absolument nécessaire j'insiste
sur ce point que les produits de
substitution fasse la preuve de leur
innocuité
il serait inoubliable d'échanger un
risque connu contre un danger mal
compris voire inconnus en tant que
responsable public l'un de nos premiers
devoirs est évidemment de protéger nos
concitoyens dans le champ sanitaire fait
de voir prend toute sa dimension
les situations que nous avons connu par
le passé nous incite à appliquer le
principe de précaution lorsque
surgissent trop d'incertitudes
elle nous oblige aussi à prendre
rapidement les décisions courageuses qui
s'imposent pour garantir un haut niveau
de protection aux français et c'est dans
cette perspective que s'inscrit la
proposition de loi aujourd'hui porté par
patricia sheen âgé et mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
je vous appelle à soutenir cette
proposition de loi à l'unanimité je vous
remercie
merci madame
istres mes chers collègues je suis
particulièrement heureux de saluer en
votre nom
la présence dans notre tribune d'honneur
d'une délégation de la chambre des
conseillers du maroc conduite par
monsieur abdellah rim atmoune conseiller
et président du groupe d'amitié
france-maroc de la chambre des
conseillers
la délégation est accompagné par
monsieur christian cambon président du
groupe d'amitié sénatoriales france
maroc et des membres de son groupe
cette délégation marocaine s'intéressent
tout particulièrement pendant sa visite
aux questions de transport notamment
transport ferroviaire avec le projet de
tgv alors que le maroc est engagé dans
un vaste mouvement de réformes
politiques économiques et sociales
nous formons le voeu que cette visite
conforte l'excellence des relations
entre nos deux pays
relation tout à la fois historique et
tournée vers l'avenir et nous leur
souhaitons la bienvenue au sénat
français dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à madame patricia
sillinger rapporteur de la commission
des affaires sociales monsieur le
président madame la ministre madame la
présidente de la commission mes chers
collègues la france comme l'ensemble des
pays occidentaux est confrontée à une
augmentation inquiétante de certaines
maladies ou épidémie que ce soit les
cancers le diabète l'obésité ou encore
la dégradation de la fertilité
or ni le vieillissement de la population
ni l'amélioration du dépistage ne
suffisent à expliquer à eux seuls ces
phénomènes ce constat est relativement
partagés mais les causalités reste
largement débattue au sein de la
communauté scientifique
on peut tout de même affirmer que de
multiples facteurs en environnementaux
jouent un rôle majeur dans cette
évolution préoccupante
parmi ces facteurs il existe un relatif
consensus pour mettre en cause des
perturbateurs endocriniens substances
étrangères à l'organisme susceptible de
bouleverser le système hormonal qui est
essentielle pour la reproduction le
métabolisme ou le comportement la
science n'apporte pas encore de réponse
précise et entièrement partagé à ce
sujet notamment sur les mécanismes qui
sont à l'oeuvre
qui plus est ce cette famille de
substances est large et hétérogène et
leurs effets et modalités d'action sont
très divers se pose alors la question de
savoir à partir de quel moment les
données scientifiques doivent être
suffisamment certaine pour qu'une
décision de santé publique soit adopté
tel est précisément la question centrale
du principe de précaution que la france
je le rappelle a inscrit dans sa
constitution
l'un de ces perturbateurs le bisphénol a
a fait l'objet de nombreuses études
depuis plusieurs années elles ont été
systématisées par l'inserm et laisse en
les expertises de ces deux organismes
permettent de faire l'état des lieux des
données actuellement disponibles
on peut en tirer les conclusions
suivantes qui peuvent servir de près
nice pour préparer notre décision
la toxicité du bpa est avérée pour
l'écosystème et pour l'animal elle est
suspectée chez l'être humain
l'alimentation constituent la source
principale principale d'exposition la
période de la gestation est critique et
constitue comme celle du début de la vie
une phase de vulnérabilité particulière
enfin le bpa ne répond pas à la proche
toxicologiques classique selon laquelle
la 2 ferait le poison des effets nocifs
sont en effet susceptibles de survenir à
faible dose en deçà des 2 journalière
tolérable définies par les
réglementations qui reste basée sur le
principe de lien entre la 2 et les faits
on peut également citer les effets coq
taille en cas de mélange de plusieurs
substances et les effets fenêtre selon
la période de la vie et les effets
transgénérationnels du bpa
c'est à dire sa capacité à produire des
effets sur la descendance
c'est dans ce cadre que s'inscrit
l'eczéma les
examen par le sénat de la proposition de
loi adoptée il y a un an à l'assemblée
nationale à la quasi unanimité
après un débat riche notre commission a
approuvé la démarche progressive et
ciblé de ce texte et je résumerais ainsi
notre approche qui se situe en corée en
en cohérence avec celle de l'assemblée
nationale suspendre dès le 1er janvier
prochain la commercialisation des
conditionnements alimentaires avec le
bpa destinés aux nourrissons et aux
enfants jusqu'à 3 ans étiqueter les
conditionnement alimentaire comportant
du bpa pour les déconseillé aux femmes
enceintes et aux enfants de moins de 3
ans notre commission à jouer a ajouté
pardon les femmes allaitantes dans cet
avertissement sanitaire à terme
suspendre l'ensemble des conditionnement
alimentaire comportant le bpa sur ma
proposition
la commission a ajouté une habilitation
pour les agents de la répression des
fraudes a contrôlé les produits et à
constater les iv éventuelle infraction
nous avons eu lé en commission et nous
l'aurons dissin naturellement un aussi
si un débat sur la date appropriée pour
cesser d'utiliser le bpa dans les
conditionnements alimentaires avant de
me présenter mes propres arguments je
souhaiterais d'abord me réjouir du fait
qu en débattant sur ce point de
chronologie nous acceptions ensemble le
principe même de la fin programmée de
l'utilisation du bpa dans les
conditionnements alimentaires
c'est un premier acquis essentiel qu'ils
n'étaient qui n'était pas nécessairement
évident au départ
je crois qu'il faut le souligner car
c'est le message principal de cette
proposition de loi
message à destination des consommateurs
mais aussi à l'ensemble de l'opinion
européenne et internationale ne collait
de l'assemblée nationale avait prévu un
délai de deux années entre l'adoption
présumée de la loi et l entrée en
vigueur de la mesure générale
d'interdiction
j'ai proposé à la commission de
conserver le ce délai
pour permettre aux chercheurs et aux
industriels de s'adapter aux
bouleversements que constitue la fin du
bpa pour lui pour l'usagé alimentaire
ce composé est en effet largement
employé dans ce secteur et ne vont pas
faire l'erreur
il ne s'agirait de l'interdire pour le
remplacer par un substitut mal adaptés
et trop vite
expertise et nous voyons bien dans tous
les débats actuels sur la qualité des
expertises
je pense par exemple aux ogm la
nécessité d' analyse sur une période
période suffisamment longue d'exposition
pour autant les signaux d'alerté
mentionné par l'inserm et parlant ne
cesse donc j'ai largement fait mention
dans mon rapport écrit nous présente
nous pressent pardon ils sont trop
précis et trop nombreux pour que nous
affaiblissons notre message en reculant
encore le terme de la substitution
n'oublions pas que cette mesure se
conjuguent
d'une part avec la suspension quasi
immédiat du bpa pour les
conditionnements alimentaires à
destination des nourrissons et des
enfants en bas âge et d'autre part avec
la création d'un avertissement sanitaire
en outre les industriels ont largement
anticipé cette décision notamment pour
des raisons d'image de marque auprès des
consommateurs et ont entamé
d'importantes recherches depuis
plusieurs années depuis une semaine j'ai
lu et entendu de nombreux commentaires
sur la décision de la commission de
conserver ce délai de deux ans je
souhaiterais simplement indiqué que ce
faisant la france sera le premier pays
au monde à adopter une mesure aussi
général c'est pourquoi je crois que le
1er janvier 2015 représente un équilibre
à la fois raisonnable et volontariste
madame la ministre je souhaiterais vous
interrogée plus précisément au sujet de
l'avertissement sanitaires prévues dans
le texte
pouvez-vous nous fournir des indications
sur le calendrier d'adoption du décret
d'application et sur le format de
l'étiquetage
on va envisager vous plutôt une
pas d' alerte ou un pictogramme à
l'image de celui déconseillant l'alcool
aux femmes enceintes dans les deux cas
le message doit être clair précis et
lisible par ailleurs on peut
légitimement penser que la commission
européenne et certains états membres ne
resteront pas inertes face à la
proposition française
d'autres états ils seront au contraire
sensibles par exemple le danemark la
suède et la belgique ont déjà pris des
mesures d'interdiction en faveur des
nourrissons et des enfants en bas âge je
crois que les dispositions que nous
allons adopter entre pleinement dans les
mesures de sauvegarde qu'un état peut
prendre selon les textes communautaires
eux mêmes il s'agit cependant de
convaincre nos partenaires et il serait
intéressant de les mobiliser et de les
sensibiliser sur cette question
notamment les députés européens
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues nous allons aujourd'hui je
l'espère à prouver le retrait progressif
des conditionnement alimentaire
comportant du bisphénol a
pour anton nous devons également nous
préoccuper des autres perturbateurs
endocriniens et des usages autres
qu'alimentaires nous en discuterons à
l'occasion des amendements mais je
souhaiterais insister sur le nécessaire
effort de recherche lors de la
conférence pour la transition écologique
le premier ministre a en effet en prime
en fait une priorité
du point de vue de la santé
environnementale je m'en réjouis
nous devons avancer rapidement et de
manière coordonnée au niveau
international sur ces questions en
conclusion je souhaite reprendre à mon
compte une phrase de la préface de l'
expertise collective de l'inserm de 2011
sur la reproduction et l'environnement
même si la complexité scientifique le
degré d'incertitude où l'ignorance ne
permettent pas de comprendre tous les
mécanismes d'action
il ne faut pas attendre la preuve de la
cause yann causalité et la compréhension
de ces mécanismes
mais pour protéger la santé des
populations c'est dans cet esprit que
j'ai abordé l'examen de la proposition
de loi qui nous est soumise et j'espère
que nous pourrons tous nous retrouver
sur l'application des principes de
précaution qu'elle prévoit je vous
remercie
merci madame le rapporteur dans la suite
de la discussion générale la parole est
à madame laurence cohen pour le groupe
crc
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues en 2010 alors que
notre haute assemblée examinait la
proposition de loi déposée par le groupe
rds les sénatrices et sénateurs du
groupe crc avait déjà proposé de tendre
vers une interdiction totale du
bisphénol a
la majorité de l'époque s'était montré
plus frileuses et avait préféré le
principe d'une suspension de la
commercialisation de produits contenant
du bisphénol a pour les seuls biberons
rien d'étonnant donc qu'aujourd'hui nous
votions en faveur de cette proposition
de loi qui conduira dès 2015 à
l'interdiction totale d'utilisation de
fabrication de commercialisation et
d'exportation du bisphénol a dans
l'ensemble des contenants alimentaires
je suis d'ailleurs persuadé que
l'adoption de cette proposition de loi
sera déterminante dans l'évolution de la
législation européenne
cela avait déjà été le cas en 2010 quand
après l'adoption la loi 2010 129 qui a
suspendu l'utilisation du bisphénol a
dans les biberons
l'union européenne a procédé à la même
mesure d'interdiction pour les biberons
à destination des enfants de moins de 12
mois
je dois d'ailleurs avoué avoir été
quelque peu surprise d'entendre en
commission des sénatrices et sénateurs
de l'opposition s'étonner que cette
proposition de loi interdise à la fois
la fabrication l'importation et
l'exportation de produits contenant du
bisphénol a
alors que d'autres pays ne l'interdît
s'aiment pas qu'aurait-il fallu faire
instaurer en france une législation
protectrice pour nos concitoyens et
accepter que les entreprises continuent
à exposer d'autres femmes et hommes
un risque sanitaire contre lequel nous
voulons prémunir la population
devrions-nous continuer à faire primer
l'exportation française face à des
dangers sanitaires potentiels
par ailleurs de plus en plus corroboré
par des experts scientifiques
ce discours qui veut faire du libre
commerce une valeur fondamentale de
notre société conduit et nous a déjà
conduit à des catastrophes écologiques
et sanitaires
cela n'est pas sans me rappeler les
dispositions contenues dans l'accord
multilatéral sur l'investissement
celui ci avait pour vous
a sion de permettre aux investisseurs
internationaux d'attaquer en justice les
pays qui avec des règlement trop strict
d'un point de vue social ou
environnemental serait obstacle à la
libéralisation du marché ou à
l'investissement
bien que de nature différente
l'observation de certains de nos
collègues de l'ump s'inspire d'une même
logique celle de la primauté de
l'économie sur l'humain et
l'environnement
nous ne pouvons naturellement pas y
souscrire la proposition de loi que nous
examinions aujourd'hui prend d'ailleurs
le contre-pied de cette posture comme
l'a d'ailleurs fait l'assemblée
nationale il a de cela un an à la quasi
unanimité
nous avons donc une responsabilité
particulière et nous devons nous
positionner non pas en tant que
scientifique ce que nous ne sommes pas
mais en tant que législateur certains
voudraient nous avons d'ailleurs reçu
beaucoup de courrier en ce sens que nous
n'adoptons pas ce texte au motif que
nous ne disposerions pas aujourd'hui de
la certitude du caractère pathogène et
dangereux du bisphénol a
force est de constater qu'aujourd'hui
encore il n'y a en la matière aucun
consensus scientifique
certes des études récentes je pense par
exemple à celles rendues publiques par
lens est ce le 27 septembre dernier
recense de nombreux effets avérés chez
les animaux l'augmentation de la
survenue de kystes ovariens l'altération
de la production spermatique
accélération de la maturation
architectural de la glande mammaire et
ce ne sont là que quelques exemples
lagence conclut d'ailleurs et je cite
qu'il existe aujourd'hui des éléments
scientifiques suffisant pour identifier
comme objectif prioritaire la prévention
des expositions des populations les plus
sensibles que sont les nourrissons et
jeunes enfants ainsi que les femmes
enceintes et allaitantes
or cette étude est contestée il ya donc
d'un côté des scientifiques qui souligne
des risques avérés ou potentiels
quand d'autres au contraire considèrent
que rien n'atteste de la dangerosité du
bisphénol
face à cette situation nous devons en
tant que parlementaire nous extraire de
ce débat scientifique qui peut durer
encore longtemps
pour mémoire et sans vouloir faire de
parallèle entre les deux sujets je
rappelle que le canada pays exportateur
d'amiante continue à nier études
scientifiques à l'appui
les dangers de l'amiante nous avons la
chance de pouvoir disposer d'un outil à
la fois majeur et incontournable
le principe de précaution qui revêt
depuis 2005 une valeur constitutionnelle
avec l'inscription de la charte de
l'environnement dans notre bloc de
constitutionnalité
en vertu de ce principe les autorités
publiques doivent agir
même si la réalisation du dommage est
incertaine y compris entre guillemets en
l'état de connaissances scientifiques
nous avons l'opportunité aujourd'hui de
donner une portée réelle à ce principe
de précaution en faisant en sorte que
sans doute pour la première fois le
législateur son inspiration même d'être
confrontés une crise sanitaire
certains considèrent que ce faisant nous
conseillerions le risque
je ne le crois pas et je suis persuadé
qu'il s'agit en réalité d'éviter qu'un
risque ne se réalise il faut nous place
et non pas en situation de l'observateur
du risque mais d'acteurs actifs
anticipant le risque ne perdons jamais
de vue le temps perdu concernant
l'amiante et combien les conséquences
ont été et sont toujours dramatique à
l'image de la théorie développée par le
philosophe hans jonas dans son ouvrage
le principe de responsabilité il nous
faut anticiper les risques et les
conséquences des décisions et des
actions prises sur les futures
générations et au delà sur les
possibilités de réparation ou de
dédommagements il s'agit donc de rompre
avec la logique du passé dans le doute
abstiens toi pour faire du doute une
raison d'agir c'est ce qui nous motive
au groupe crc
c'est pourquoi nous voterons cette loi
merci ma chère collègue
la parole est à madame chantal jouanno
pour le groupe ump vous êtes la parole
madame la ministre
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
vous savez la question du bisphénol a
est un combat qui me tient à coeur parce
qu'en tant que secrétaire d'état à
l'écologie à l'époque j'avais eu madame
la ministre a opposé un peu à la
direction générale de la santé qui m'a
affirmé qu'il n'y avait aucun sujet sur
le bisphénol a et c'est bien le le
prédécesseur de landes c'est ce qui par
ses avis avait permis de faire bouger
les choses et aujourd'hui le dernier
avis de l'ansès nous le montre à nouveau
on ne peut plus cacher derrière cette
logique où cet argument de l'ignorance
nous avons le devoir de nous poser de
bonnes questions
nous avons le devoir de reconnaître que
si l'espérance de vie augmente
globalement dans notre pays
l'espérance de vie sans handicap elle
augmente beaucoup moins vite et au sein
de la commission des affaires sociales
régulièrement nous constatons que de
grandes maladies et épidémies de ce
siècle que ce soit le cancer l'obésité
le diabète les maladies
neurodégénératives ne s'explique pas par
l'analyse sanitaire dit classique
et justement cette proposition de loi
sur le bisphénol a est probablement
l'occasion d'inscrire dans la loi des
principes sanitaires nouveau parce qu'en
réalité le bisphénol a est un cas type
qui n'est pas très compliqué et qui ne
relèvent pas du principe de précaution
mais du principe de prévention puisque
nous avons quand même beaucoup d'études
kung fu concordantes
nous savons que le bisphénol a le bpa
est un astre gène de synthèse donc pas
étonnant qu il ait des effets des
perturbateurs endocriniens nous savons
que le foetus et les bébés sont
particulièrement vulnérables
nous savons que 90% de la population est
touchée
en d'autres termes la vague le mans
n'est pas de mise et aujourd'hui les
connaissances nous oblige à agir
compte tenu des avis des experts que ce
soit lente c'est ce live tiers ou même
des experts non publique
tous les avis convergent pour dire que
la priorité absolue et je voudrais
insister sur ce point la priorité
absolue c'est le foetus donc là femmes
enceintes et allaitantes et les enfants
et puisque les bébés passionne
généralement assez peu la gente
masculine je voudrais ajouter à votre
attention messieurs vous êtes
relativement nombreux aujourd'hui c'est
une chance quelques mois de l'étude de
l'inserm
on ne peut pas considérer que le
bisphénol a aux doses auxquelles la
population générale est exposée soit
sans danger pour le versant masculin de
la reproduction
messieurs vous conviendrait donc que
nous avons le devoir politique
d'inscrire dans la loi le principe de
non exposition au bisphénol a du foetus
et des jeunes enfants et j'ai déposé un
amendement pour inscrire ce principe de
santé publique dans la loi je ne doute
pas que vous le vôtre et parce que c'est
un principe simple c'est un principe
général que le législateur pose à
l'exécutif le texte me semble également
trop restrictif sur le champ des
produits concernés
vous le savez le lait maternel par
exemple est largement autant contaminés
que le lait qui était auparavant contenu
dans les biberons au bisphénol a et plus
encore les études préparatoires sur la
cohorte elfe on soulignait l'importance
de la présence de bisphénol a chez les
mères et donc les bébés lors des
accouchements médicalisé tous les
produits au contact des femmes enceintes
ou allaitantes et des bébés doivent donc
exclure la présence de bpa et de
bisphénol a est même plus globalement
des perturbateurs endocriniens c'était
d'ailleurs une des conclusions de notre
mission d'information sur les
dispositifs médicaux implantables
mission d'information qui je vous le
rappelle
dans les conclusions ont été adoptés à
l'unanimité y compris par la commission
des affaires sociales
aussi je vous proposerait deux
amendements un amendement relativement
large excluant la présence de
perturbateurs endocriniens dans tous les
dispositifs médicaux à destination dé
nous
ils sont tout particulièrement
d'ailleurs des prématurés et un
amendement de repli qui se limite au
bisphénol a et j'ajoute que j'ai mis un
certain délai pour que cette disposition
puisse entrer en vigueur
je pense que ce sont et je l'espère des
amendements consensuelle et madame la
ministre j'ai bien écouté votre discours
vous avez affirmé que nous devions à
prix appliqués de manière la plus
stricte
le principe de précaution même si je
préfèrerais parler de principe de
prévention pour les bébés en
l'occurrence nous avons l'occasion de
l'appliquer par contre dernier dernier
point s'agissant du calendrier multiples
débats dans la commission sur la
question du calendrier
certains ont acheté le spectre des
lobbys contre l'interdiction du
bisphénol a et des lobbys qui aurait
obtenu le report d'un an de
l'interdiction dans tous les contenants
alimentaires
en lités c'est plutôt c'est un faux
débat c'est logique d'avoir des
garanties sur l'inocuité des produits de
substitution
d'autant qu'en l'occurrence je le
rappelle nous parlons d'impact à long
terme de faibles doses de polluants et
sur ce point la proposition de loi me
semblent relativement équilibrées
nous avons même d'ailleurs déposé un
amendement pour que d'ici janvier 2015
on apporte bien la preuve de l'innocuité
des produits de substitution
par contre j'ai relu je vous répète
parce que je trouve qu'on se trompe
parfois débat je trouverai un
justiciable que nous soyons plus
restrictif pour les adultes que pour les
enfants et je suis assez surprise
d'ailleurs d'avoir un temps dû y compris
en commission que le problème économique
n'était pas un sujet pour l'ensemble des
contenants alimentaires mais peur que
par contre on pouvait y avoir un
problème économique pour les dispositifs
médicaux à destination des enfants qui
justifierait qu'on adopte pas cette
cette disposition
voilà mesdames
et messieurs mes chers collègues on a
l'occasion aujourd'hui de poser les
bases d'une nouvelle politique sanitaire
une nouvelle approche qui sont un peu en
rupture avec la toxicologie classique
selon laquelle seule la dose fait le
poison ce qui est le principe de base de
la dose journalière acceptable parce que
les expertises sur le bpa et sur les
perturbateurs endocriniens je vous
rapporte je vous renvoie au rapport de
monsieur barbier montrait clairement que
l'insuffisance de cette approche qui
ignore les effets à long terme des
effets cocktails les effets fenêtres et
nous avons aussi par cette loi la
possibilité de montrer que les grands
dépôts de les grandes épidémies les
grandes maladies seront plus facilement
prévenu que traiter et d'ailleurs si
j'avais un peu de temps je vous
renverrai aussi à la nécessité de
pratiquer un exercice physique quotidien
et un bon équilibre alimentaire qui avec
la réduction des expositions est la
meilleure garantie pour une longue et
bonne santé mais malheureusement ces
dispositifs de santé publique ces deux
logiques de prévention ça fait des
années qu'on en parle avec des années
qu'on en parle
même sur les bancs d'école et ça fait
des années qu'on avance très très peu
sur ces sujets c'est le parent pauvre de
la plupart des débats écologiques et des
débats sanitaire d'ailleurs y compris à
la conférence environnementale la seule
décision sur la santé environnementale
de la conférence environnementale a été
de reprendre cette cette proposition de
loi donc vraiment pour conclure sous
l'apparence d'un texte qui peut être
très technique
sous l'apparence d'un texte qui
manifestement ne concerne pas tout le
monde
nous avons vraiment la possibilité
d'inscrire dans la loi des principes
nous vous de santé publique et de donner
corps à quelques principes de base de
santé environnementale c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'ai voté le texte de la
commission
mais je souhaite vivement qu'on puisse
quand même l'enrichir je vous remercie
merci
chers collègues la parole est à monsieur
gilbert barbier pour le groupe rds
c'est le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
utilisez donc depuis de nombreuses
années plus de 50 ans dans la
fabrication des polycarbonates des
résines époxy le bisphénol a est un
perturbateur endocrinien avérés et les
expérimentations animales très
certainement aussi nocif chez l'homme
même si les études épidémiologiques sont
encore balbutiantes
c'est la raison pour laquelle en 2010
plusieurs sénateurs du groupe rdse avait
alerté le gouvernement ait déposé un au
nom du principe de précaution qui vient
d'être évoqué une proposition de loi
visant à l'interdire dans les plastiques
alimentaires principales voies de
contamination
il est vrai qu'à ce moment là les
diverses agences sanitaires estimé que
le bpa n'était pas forcément dangereux
pour l'homme que les preuves étaient
insuffisantes pour justifier une
interdiction aussi le sénat avait
préféré en limiter la portée
nous avions donc choisi de suspendre
uniquement la commercialisation des
biberons produits à base de bisphénol a
s'agissait malgré tout d'une première
étape très importante à la suite de
l'examen de cette proposition de loi
notre commission des affaires sociales
elle est souhaité être éclairé sur les
mesures législatives qui seront
éventuellement adoptées sur la question
des perturbateurs endocriniens de la
santé elle avait donc décidé de saisir
l'office parlementaire d'évaluation des
choix scientifiques et technologiques
j'ai eu l'honneur d'être rapporteur de
cette mission au cours des nombreuses
auditions que j'ai pu mais il m'est
apparu que les dangers et les risques
des perturbateurs endocriniens casser
ces mères pour l'environnement et la
santé humaine était suffisamment
nombreux et précis pour inciter à
l'action
aussi j'avais préconisé à l'époque
notamment une démarche immédiate de
prévention notamment par l'étiquetage
des produits l interdiction des
perturbateurs endocriniens dans les
produits destinés aux femmes enceintes
et aux jeunes enfants
ces deux catégories de personnes n'étant
des sites particulièrement vulnérables
ou perturbateur endocrinien
plusieurs études ont confirmé le danger
du but
ep 1 je pense notamment ça a été évoqué
l' expertise collective de l'inserm
d'avril 2011 concernant cinq grandes
familles de substances chimiques et non
pas seulement du bisphénol-a où il y
aurait des effets reprotoxiques je pense
également aux deux rapports de l'ansès
en septembre 2011 qui a permis de mettre
en évidence des effets sanitaires avérés
chez l'animal et suspectés chez l'homme
et ce même des niveaux d'exposition très
faible car contrairement à lapproche
toxicologiques classique basé sur la
relation dose effet des doses très
faibles bien au-dessous de la dgi à la
douche journalières admissibles sont
susceptibles d'avoir plus d'impact que
des doses élevées
l'ansès a donc recommandé la réduction
des expositions au bisphénol a notamment
par sa substitution dans les matériaux
au contact des denrées alimentaires et
lesquels constituent la source
principale d'exposition
aussi je me félicite que le sénat est
inscrit cette proposition de loi à
l'ordre du jour ah non après son examen
par l'assemblée nationale pression pour
autant que je refuse que ce texte ne
soit un effet d'annonce ans nous devons
en effet être réaliste et pragmatique
voter des lois applicables
et en l'espèce nous devons laisser le
temps aux industriels de s'adapter de
trouver des substituts dont l'innocuité
ne fera aucun doute il y travaille
depuis quelques années il faut bien le
dire mais déjà les produits de
remplacement ne sont pas tous
scientifiquement validées soyons
exigeants mais aussi patient d'autant
que très récemment des chercheurs de
l'inserm et du cnrs à montpellier on
analyser les interactions existantes
entre le bpa est les récepteurs des
oestrogènes
ces travaux pourraient permettre de
créer de nouveaux composés avec les
mêmes propriétés que le bpa mais non
toxique la santé de nos concitoyens nous
impose de ne pas légiférer dans la
précipitation
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
proposerai un amendement reportant
l'interdiction
au 1er janvier 2015 par ailleurs et
j'insiste sur ce point notre action pour
être efficace doit s'inscrire dans une
perspective plus large au niveau
européen ce qui n'est pas sans soulever
quelques difficultés si l'on peut se
réjouir qu à lens s propose dans le
cadre du règlement reach de classe et
plus sévèrement le bisphénol a en tant
que toxiques pour la reproduction et que
le parlement européen s'apprête à goûter
en février prochain un rapport sur la
protection de la santé publique contre
les perturbateurs endocriniens
on ne peut que s'inquiéter de la récente
passe d'armes au sein des autorités
européennes
alors que la direction générale de
l'environnement travaille déjà sur ce
sujet la direction générale de la santé
des consommateurs vient de confier le
développement de la définition des
perturbateurs endocriniens à l'autorité
européenne de sécurité des aliments qui
continue de nier la véracité des données
scientifiques
madame le ministre nous devons être
particulièrement vigilant sur
l'évolution au niveau européen je pense
que pourrait intervenir dans ce sens en
face s'agissant de la mise en place d'un
pictogramme d'avertissement nous avons
été plusieurs en commission a dénoncé
l'inefficacité de ce qui figure sur les
bouteilles de produits alcoolisés
pourquoi ne pas prévoir un message
simple et visible comme c'est déjà le
cas pour les biberons ou pour les
produits cosmétiques concernant le
présence de parabène où l'on aujourd'hui
la preuve de la nocivité du bpa est fait
certes je l' ai déjà dit des travaux
était démis logique notamment en france
sont rares mais de vous à nous pour
autant attendre les résultats d'études
plus poussées sur les êtres humains
comme la cohorte elfe ou les conclusions
ne seront vraiment connu que dans arrête
ou 30 ans je ne le crois pas je pense au
contraire qu'il est de notre
responsabilité de légiférer en fixant
des échéances réaliste dans la
concertation avec les professionnels de
la filière agroalimentaire
c'est un devoir pour tous envers nos
concitoyens les générations futures
mais pour moi la question ne doit pas se
limiter aux seuls bisphénol a il faudra
bien rapidement à élargir le débat à
tous les perturbateurs endocriniens
adhérer dans le contexte général des
substances cancérogènes mutagènes et
reprotoxiques c'est le cas des phtalates
des parabènes les retardateurs de flamme
dont l'arrêt proxité est assez largement
avéré aussi dans l'immédiat il me paraît
urgent tna j'ai déposé un amendement
dans ce sens de contrôler plus
étroitement les dispositifs médicaux
notamment dans le secteur de
l'obstétrique n1 pédiatrie et c'est dans
ce sens que je propose un amendement sur
les phtalates utilisés dans le matériel
d'alimentation parentérale stalag
d'ailleurs déjà interdits dans les
jouets et les matériaux au contact des
jeunes enfants je pense que nous en
agissant dans ce sens
eh bien nous ferons avancer ce problème
de protection de nos concitoyens et
notamment les femmes enceintes et les
plus jeunes enfants ce qui me semble la
priorité merci mon cher collègue bien la
parole est à madame aline archimbaud
pour le groupe écologie
monsieur le président madame la ministre
madame la rapporteure madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales chers collègues le bisphénol a
est à l'heure actuelle l'un des produits
chimiques les plus produits au monde
avec plus de 3 millions 800 mille tonnes
par an pour un marché mondial de 6
milliards de dollars parmi d'autres le
travail méticuleux entrepris par le
réseau environnement santé recense
toutes les études sortant sur le sujet
soit un peu plus de 700 ans tous les
conclusions de 95 % d'entre elles sont
concordantes
le bisphénol a a un effet délétère sur
nos organismes et ce à plusieurs niveaux
aujourd'hui nous savons que le bisphénol
a est un perturbateur endocrinien qu'il
est cancérigène et qu'il est
neurotoxiques des centaines d'études
menées sur cette substance ressortent
que le bpa a des effets sur l'organisme
à différentes périodes de notre vis
comprenant entre autres des changements
comportementaux une altération de la
croissance un avancement de la
maturation sexuelle secondaire d
altération du système nerveux
une prédisposition à l'obésité des
effets profonds sur le métabolisme du
glucose pouvant favoriser le
développement de diabète des effets
reproductif telles qu'une baisse de la
qualité du sperme et des liaisons de
l'adn du sperme une augmentation du
risque de cancer des effets
neurotoxiques surtout ses effets sont
héréditaires et transgénérationnelle
même à des niveaux d'exposition très
faible comparable aux concentrations de
bpa retrouver dans la plus grande part
de la population humaine occidental
certains de mes collègues ont comparé
l'ampleur du désastre ou scandale de
l'amiante les conséquences potentielles
sont en fait si on peut dire même pire
puisque il ne suffira pas d'interdire le
bisphénol a et de l'éliminer
physiquement de notre environnement pour
que ses effets sur les populations
disparaissent il faudra aussi attendre
et attendre suffisamment pour que passe
plusieurs générations si l'on se
concentre sur la période alors
d'octobre 2011 à septembre 2012 on
recense 140 trois études sur le
bisphénol a et ses effets chez l'homme
et chez l'animal sur ses 143 étude seuls
9 n'ont pas montré d'effets donc 3 chez
l'animal et six chez l'homme j'entends
encore certains de mes collègues ou
lobby particulièrement mobilisé sur la
question remettre en cause la fiabilité
des études et j'en profite pour me
permettre une petite parenthèse est
appelé un changement de paradigme
concernant l'évaluation des risques et
la santé publique la controverse
scientifique autour du bpa telle que
nous l'avons évoqué mais d'abord en
évidence des divergences de premier
ordre sur les méthodes scientifiques
d'évaluation dans le domaine sanitaire
lors de leur évaluation de la
littérature scientifique sur le
bisphénol a
les agences sanitaires ou non des jeux
site bonnes pratiques de laboratoire
fermez les guillemets ne prennent
souvent en compte que les études
financées par l'industrie excluant des
centaines d'études indépendantes ne
répondant pas à ces critères bien
qu'elles permettent parfois d'observer
bien plus finement la réalité par
ailleurs les études montrant les effets
les effets faible dose du bpa
en écho à celles d'autres perturbateurs
endocriniens ont bouleversé et mon
collègue l'a souligné précédemment ont
bouleversé le principe selon lequel la
dose fait le poison avec certaines
trouvant davantage d'effets pour les
expositions à faible dose que celles à
forte dose elle suggère aussi que la
période d'exposition est aussi à prendre
en compte de la controverse scientifique
sur l'innocuité du bpa découle donc une
injonction logique à changer de
paradigme d'évaluation des risques
sanitaires pour en revenir à la présente
proposition de loi le groupe écologiste
qui appelle de ses voeux une telle
décision depuis des années se réjouit
bien entendu du texte sous ses yeux
même s'il fait que ce soit les
parlementaires qui est aujourd'hui à se
prononcer sur une telle décision
souligne les lacunes des systèmes
française de sécurité sanitaire ce dont
nous aurons l'occasion de reparler lundi
après-midi lors de l'examen du texte
ma collègue marie christine blandin sur
l'indépendance de l'expertisé et la
protection des lanceurs d'alerté
quoi qu'il en soit bien sûr nous
voterons pour cette proposition de loi
et saluons l'initiative et le travail de
notre collègue député gérard bapt est de
notre collègue sénatrice rapporteur
aujourd'hui toutefois cela ne nous
empêche pas d'avoir quelques remarques à
faire en plus des amendements que nous
présenterons relatif d'une part aux
matériels médicaux et aux perturbateurs
endocriniens en général et que je serai
amené à défendre tout à l'heure pour
ceux de mes collègues qui s'inquiètent
du délai trop court que constituerait le
1er janvier 2015 pour l'entrée en
application de l'interdiction du
bisphénol a
je veux leur répondre que la proposition
de notre rapporteur patrice achille
âgées de reculer d'un an la date
contenus dans la ppl nous provenant de
l'assemblée est déjà une décision
extrêmement coûteuse pour nous
écologistes et qui prend déjà en compte
les difficultés du tissu industriel à
s'adapter aux changements de normes
surtout en période de crise et surtout
pour les pme
compte tenu des enjeux énormes en termes
de santé publique que j'ai décrit
précédemment sachez qu'il s'agit du
maximum acceptable par une pour nous et
qu'il est hors de question que nous
cédions un jour de plus de nombreuses
alternatives fiables existent au bpa
dans le plastique polycarbonate et il ya
également des alternatives au revêtement
des emballages métalliques boîtes de
conserve canettes et caetera et donc je
voudrais pour terminer citer aussi les
autres options d'emballage qui existent
du type brique cartonné et également
beaucoup en verre et finalement à la
proche de l'examen du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
ma dernière remarque sera d'ordre
financier madame la ministre dans le
dossier explicatif qui accompagne le
plfss ce 2013 est mentionné page 19
la volonté de faire face à la montée des
pathologies chroniques
je cite liées au vieillissement de notre
société
vous n'êtes vous savez que bien sûr le
bisphénol en particulier les
perturbateurs endocriniens angers
ral ont une lourde part de
responsabilité dans cette épidémie de
maladies chroniques et or cette épidémie
est l'une des principales causes de
l'inflation de nos dépenses d'assurance
maladie le diabète par exemple dont j'ai
expliqué précisément qu'il était
favorisé par le bisphénol à coûte près
de 15 milliards d'euros par an à
l'assurance maladie à mettre en
perspective avec les 13,9 milliards de
déficit de la sécurité sociale prévu
pour 2012
madame la ministre chers collègues nous
espérons que nos propositions seront
sauront retenir votre attention que les
délais de seconde lecture de publication
des décrets de la présente proposition
de loi tiendront compte de la gravité
des enjeux et de l'urgence à agir
merci merci madame archimbaud la parole
létale monsieur gérard dériot zea parole
monsieur le questeur
girard tirelire
chez le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues fin janvier 2010
l'agencé française de sécurité sanitaire
des aliments donc la fsa rendait un avis
mitigé sur les effets toxiques du
bisphénol a
or le 23 juin 2010 l'assemblée nationale
adopté conforme à la proposition de loi
de notre collègue yvon collin dont j'ai
eu l'honneur d'être rapporteur et non
pas l'assemblée nationale en premier
madame la ministre c'est bien le sénat
qui a voté le premier la suppression ou
tout au moins la suspension de la
fabrication et de la vente des biberons
qui contenait du bisphénol simplement
c'était ce n'est pas du tout par souci
de compétitivité entre l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat mais je tenais en
l'occurrence que la vérité soit rétablie
c'était une satisfaction pour l'ensemble
de nos collègues sénateurs
ce faisant la france interdisait la
fabrication donc et la commercialisation
de biberons contenant du bisphénol a et
devenez l'un des deux seuls pays
européens avec le danemark à mettre en
place cette interdiction
je rappelle que deux facteurs de risques
identifiés par des études scientifiques
nous avait conduit à cette décision
d'une part ce que ce dont personne n'a
parlé ici et qui pourtant primordial
c'est qu'à partir du chauffage
relativement intense de produits
contenant du bisphénol que celui-ci se
libère et vient éventuellement
contaminer les produits alimentaires ou
le lait pour enfants qui se trouvent
dans les récipients
c'est donc ça le problème majeur ce
n'est pas simplement parce que vous
traversez je vais faire je vais dire un
nuage de bisphénol que vous allez
forcément vous vous contaminer au
bisphénol mais justement il est
nécessaire et indispensable d'être
vigilants et c'est bien cela que nous
avions souhaité au sénat est ce que
j'avais proposé à l'époque c'est à dire
que pour les biberons qui trop souvent
sont chauffées dans un micro-ondes et
puis des fois oublié quant à la
température parce que évidemment on ne
fait pas boire un
libre ont chauffé à kelly ébullition un
bébé c'est évident mais après
refroidissement il n'est pas rare de
voir re donner le biberon et à partir de
là le bisphénol libéré et vient
contaminer et c'est là le vrai problème
scientifique c'est que ce sont avant
tout par des récipients chauffée à une
température trop élevée que le bisphénol
se libère mais aussi s'adressant à des
bébés à des nourrissons ce sont eux
évidemment les plus sensibles à tout
cela puisque le bisphénol a comme cela a
été rappelé est un perturbateur
endocrinien et que forcément ce sont les
embryons est les nourrissons qui sont
avec un système mans hormonal encore
immature qui sont les plus sensibles
même si les doutes sur tous les doutes
scientifique n'était pas totalement levé
les suspicions était suffisamment forte
pour que l'union européenne décide à son
tour le 1er juin 2011 l'interdiction de
la commercialisation et de l'importation
des biberons contenant du bisphénol a
je souhaite insister sur le fait que le
bisphénol a est bien effectivement comme
ça a été rappelé un perturbateur
endocrinien
malheureusement parmi beaucoup d'autres
et il est vrai que notre collègue
gilbert barbier elle a rappelé tout à
l'heure à travers le rapport qu'il avait
fait et bien nous savons que bon nombre
d'entre eux ont forcément des effets
néfastes pour la santé
et comme cela vient d'être rappelé le
bpa est utilisé depuis plus de 40 ans
pour la fabrication industrielle de
plastique comme le polycarbonate
il sert également à fabriquer des
résines employé comme antioxydant dans
les plastifiants et le pvc
nous le retrouvons donc dans de nombreux
objets quotidiennement utilisés
le polycarbonate qui est le type de
plastique rigide et transparent et qui
est largement utilisé dans des objets au
contact des aliments et des liquides les
résines époxydes quant à elles font
l'objet de plusieurs types d'emplois
elles sont utilisées en tant que
revêtement de surfaces notamment dans
les canettes les ouates deux concernent
ainsi que dans certaines canalisations
d'eau les conteneurs d'eau potable et
les cuves à vin
elle assure également l'étanchéité de
récipients en verre ce qui garantit la
salubrité de l'aliment à l'époque de
l'interdiction des biberons fabriqués à
partir de bpa
le débat sur l'élargissement de cette
interdiction avait été posée aujourd'hui
nous passons à une autre étape avec la
proposition de loi qui nous vient donc
de l'assemblée nationale en effet je le
rappelle ce texte prévoit quatre mesures
distinctes
l'interdiction la fabrication de
l'importation de l'exportation et de la
commercialisation de tout
conditionnement comportant du bisphénol
un destiné à recevoir des produits
alimentaires et ce à compter du 1er
janvier 2014
cette suspension prendrait effet à
compter du 1er janvier 2013 pour les
conditionnements destinés aux enfants de
moins de 3 ans bien sûr les
conditionnements aux femmes enceintes et
aux enfants de moins de 3 ans du fait de
la présence de bisphénol devront
comporter un avertissement sanitaire
déconseillant leur usage un rapport
d'étape devrait être élaboré par la
lanxess sur les substituts au bpa ainsi
que leur innocuité et leur adaptation
pour l'utilisation dans la fabrication
des plastiques et résines à usage
alimentaire est communiqué par le
gouvernement au parlement au plus tard
le 31 octobre 2012
notre commission des affaires sociales
sur proposition de ce rapporteur
patricia sillinger a décidé de repousser
la date d'entrée en vigueur de
l'interdiction dans les contenants
alimentaires et de l'apporter au 1er
janvier 2015
il nous semble par ailleurs que en
dehors d'un problème de santé publique
qui pour la plupart de son problème a
été réglé à travers la suppression des
biberons contenant du bisphénol puisque
je le répète ce sont ceux qui d'une
manière générale sont chauffés donc avec
un risque de diffusion de miss ionale
que deuxièmement s'adressant aux bébés
aux nourrissons
ce sont ceux qui sont les plus sensibles
au bisphénol puisque là encore
et bien c'est à eux que s'adresse et que
leur système hormonal n'est pas encore
terminé de n'est pas complètement mature
ce problème là était effectivement
propre très problématique et il fallait
le régler mais donc il semble toutefois
que ce délai pour nous nous semble
insuffisant pour permettre à la filière
d'un peu des emballages plastiques et à
celle des emballages métalliques et plus
généralement à tout le secteur de
l'agroalimentaire secteurs cruciaux de
s'adapter à ces nouvelles normes dans
d'aussi court délai je peux d'ores et
déjà vous indiquer que la dangerosité
des substituts est une préoccupation
majeure pour notre groupe
l'ansès a publié une note en juin 2012
présentant un certain nombre de
substitut mais rien dans aucun pardon
nous avons eu la certitude que toutes
les études permettant de définir une
hymne une innocuité total soit
effectivement donné s'agissant des
résines des substituts ont été
identifiés les plus anciens et les plus
connus sont les polyesters le vinyle le
poly acrylate ou encore l'acrylique
comme vous le savez à ce stade je le
répète aucune étude ne permet de
garantir l'innocuité de ces matériaux au
contact des aliments
je vais voir à vous rappeler que le
problème il est double c'est que si vous
n'avez pas un protecteur que vous pouvez
mettre à l'intérieur des récipients dans
lesquels vous allez mettre des produits
alimentaires vous risquez de par
l'acidité ou ou la will surtout
l'acidité des produits que vous mettez
une attaque des récipients et qui
deviennent à ce moment-là plus dangereux
que le produit lui-même puisque là ce
sera une une attaque directe par exemple
de la muqueuse stomacale où ce sera avec
une contamination extérieure tout à fait
possible parce que je le rappelle
le bisphénol servait également pour
éviter le contact avec l'extérieur
il évitait le contact avec une canette
par exemple en aluminium ou avec un
programme étals quelconque et il éviter
justement villiers le contact avec
l'extérieur
aujourd'hui pour l'instant et après tous
les renseignements que nous avons pu
prendre
d'une part nous n'avons aucun autre
produit qui remplissent qu'il remplisse
complètement cette fonction et
deuxièmement nous n'avons surtout pas
l'assurance d'une innocuité total de ses
produits de substitution alors il est
prévu une présentation détaillée des
substantielle une alternative au bpa
recensés par l' agence soit développée
par lançait ce soit à développer dans un
rapport d'expertisé collective dont la
publication de votre être réalisée d'ici
la fin de l'année
nous construisons considérons que la
décision de retirer le bo les contenants
alimentaires alimentaire doit s'appuyer
obligatoirement sur un tel rapport
pouvons-nous dire avec certitude que les
alternatives au pp à identifier ne
présentent pas de risques dans les
applications alimentaires
ces substances ont elles fait l'objet
d'évaluation de risques approfondie la
réponse je le regrette et non pour
l'instant tout en se fixant l'objectif
de l'interdiction générale du bpa et
après avoir réglé comme je le rappelais
tout à l'heure le cas des biberons qui
était la véritable source de mes faits
ultérieure il faut à mon avis se donner
un peu de temps mais aussi mettre les
industriels devant leurs responsabilités
afin qu'ils accélèrent leurs recherches
mais je rappelle aussi que les
industriels ne sont pas les seuls
tout au moins c'est pas forcément eux
qui font les recherches c'est tout tout
ce qui concerne la chimie en général et
que manifestement jusqu'à présent rien
n'a pu être identifiée comme remplissant
tous ces critères le bpa évite donc les
aliments entre en contact direct avec
l'aluminium d'une canette
s'ils étaient contaminés et attaquer les
muqueuses stomacale le risque pour la
santé seraient à mon avis bien plus
grand je fais mienne la position du chef
du gouvernement de monsieur le premier
ministre qui a déclaré lors de la
conférence environnementale le 15
septembre dernier
soutenir cette proposition de loi
d'ailleurs je crois savoir qu'il avait
signé tout comme vous madame la ministre
soit avec donc ils soutenaient cette
proposition de loi
sous réserve que les produits de
substitution et fait la preuve de leur
innocuité
je le cite il ne faudrait donc pas pour
reprendre l'expression que j'avais
modestement à l'époque utilisé en 2010
que le remède soit pire que le mal pour
conclure madame la ministre je pense que
si le principe de précaution peut
s'expliquer légitimement étant donné
l'enjeu de santé publique
il doit impérativement être accompagné
de mesures adéquates
en effet la précipitation pourrait au
final se révéler de mauvais conseil
c'est pourquoi avec plusieurs de mes
collègues je demande le report de
l'interdiction totale du bpa dans les
conditionnements à vocation alimentaire
d'une part pour que soient effectués les
tests sur les substituts et que leur
innocuité total soit avérée d'autre part
pour permettre à l'industrie agro
alimentaire de s'adapter dans de bonnes
conditions car là aussi il y a derrière
la vie et la survie de bon nombre de
personnes il est donc indispensable que
ces deux critères soient totalement pris
en compte et c'est pourquoi nous
proposerons tout à l'heure à travers un
amendement de repousser après la
proposition de patricia sillinger de
repousser d'un an est bien de mettre un
nom supplémentaire car il nous semble
que 2013 on y est donc 2014-2015 ça fait
trois ans ça me semble être le minimum
pour qu'enfin on puisse identifier un
produit de substitution
y avoir le temps de faire le maximum de
tests d'innocuité pour que nous soyons
sur les a's et les autres et bien
effectivement nous avons pleinement
rempli rempli notre rôle et nous avons
alerté l'ensemble de la société pour que
ce problème de santé de santé soient
réglés à son tour merci merci monsieur
le questeur la parole est au président
bernard cazeau pour le groupe socialiste
je
monsieur le président mon ministre
madame la rapporteure mes chers
collègues le 22 juin 2011 notre collègue
gérard bapt a déposé à l'assemblée
nationale une proposition de loi visant
l'interdiction du bisphénol a dans les
contenants alimentaires proposition
rapporté aujourd'hui par notre collègue
patricia si danger le bpa sert à la
fabrication du polycarbonate plastique
solides et transparents utilisés
on les trouve dans les récipients pour
micro-onde des bonbonnes d'eau du
matériel médical a déjà été dit et ce
sont ces souvent par l'intermédiaire des
résines époxydes hagerty qui tapissent
l'intérieur des boîtes que ce se passe
le transfert du bisphénol
préalablement le le 5 février 2010 l'
agence française de sécurité intérieure
aliments à ross a rendu un avis sur le
bpa qui mettaient en évidence des effets
sanitaires avérés chez l'animal et
suspectés chez l'homme fertilité
féminine problèmes cardiovasculaires
diabète etc et ce à de faibles niveaux
d'exposition ce qui est important tout
en indiquant que bien sûr les procédé à
des recherches approfondies pour un
cerner d'éventuels dangers sur la santé
sur l'effet de la substance proprement
dite sur le nourrisson le rapport a noté
que l'impact de ce projet ni combien
tribus se produirait sans effet seuil
en clair plus la santé de tweets de
l'utilisateur du bpa est fragile les
conséquences risquent d'être graves
d'axa avait été affirmatif à ce sujet
tandis qu'elle était moins catégorique
en ce qui concerne les risques des fûts
chez l'adulte sur son su ce sujet
d'ailleurs et ça a été dit par gérard
dériot tout à l'heure il y avait des
recommandations ne pas porter à
ébullition les biberons et ses effets
plus c'est pour cela qu'en 2010 nos
collègues
vos collants nous a fait voter
l'interdiction de la fabrication
commercialisation des biberons contenant
du bpa en france et cette loi de juillet
2010 su confirmer bien sûr pas sa
création elle était plus tard lorsque le
parlement européen proscrit
définitivement la mise sur le marché et
l'implantation en europe de biberons
contenant cette substance ce qui montre
bien que l'europe suis très souvent non
recommandations et qu'elle est très
sensibilisé dans cette affaire faut-il
aller au delà c'est la question posée
par la proposition de loi de notre
collègue gérant banques
nous croyons en effet comme l'attestent
le rapport de madame sillage il a été
montré que cette mesure spécifique
d'interdiction biberons ne couvre pas
toutes des applications et notamment les
petits pots pour bébé mais aussi les
assiettes les bols des gobelets les baby
couple décide les stérilisateurs et j'en
passe des boîtes de lait
or ces produits contiennent également du
bpa il y a là une fâcheuse incohérence à
l'essai sur le march 2 mais nous savons
que certains aliments conditionnés dans
des emballages contenant du bisphénol a
sont ingurgités and if i indifféremment
d'ailleurs par les adultes ou les
enfants aussi si la proposition de loi
de notre collègue colère étaient
nécessaires elles se révèlent
aujourd'hui tout à fait insuffisantes
comme l'a indiqué dès à la cour de
justice des communautés européennes dans
lors d'un arrêt rendu le 7 juillet 2009
il est des sujets comme la santé humaine
ou l'environnement où l'on ne peut se
contenter d'attendre des preuves avérées
du risque encouru pour agir par cc c'est
clair l'absence de certitudes compte
tenu des connaissances scientifiques et
techniques du moment ne doit pas
retarder l'adoption de mesures
préventives et proportionnées visant à
prévenir un danger sanitaire
aussi nous ne régleront pas le problème
des risques de santé du bpa pour les
publics à risque si nous ne projet
protégeons pas l'ensemble de
l'alimentation
sion le danemark la belgique la suède
ont déjà fait le canada et l'australie
et plusieurs états américains vont dans
ce sens coupes sociales du sénat
souhaite que la france se rejoignent ces
nations il approuve le compte tenu
notamment des ministres de cette
proposition de loi
toutefois en raison du trop long
cheminement législatif puis de 17 mois
d'attentes entre son inscription à
l'assemblée nationale le 22 juin 2011 et
son examen aujourd'hui au sénat nous
avons eu besoin d'actualiser ce texte la
semaine dernière en commission quatre
amendements d'ailleurs ont été adoptés à
l'unanimité pratiquement pas tout à fait
à cette attention et font partie du
texte comme c'est la règle aujourd'hui
le premier concerne la tête de
suspension de fabrication tout
conditionnement à vocation alimentaire
contenant du bisphénol a qui passent du
1er janvier 2014 au 1er janvier 2015
comme cela a été dit pour permettre aux
industriels et surtout aux pme
d'ailleurs parce qu'elle est les grandes
entreprises ont déjà
prix pris le virage pour leur permettre
de se retourner
nous quittons l'hémicycle du sénat merci
à vous d'avoir suivi le débat sur cette
proposition de loi qui je vous le
rappelle vise à interdire le bisphénol a
dans les contenants alimentaires tout de
suite l'émission politique de la
rédaction de public sénat preuve par 3
qui reçoit ce soir le candidat à la
présidence de l'ump jean françois copé
bonne soirée à tous